it must be true because it's on a
t-shirt hello guys and welcome to Friday
eree first and foremost my name is grace
Helbig I guess I feel the need to
introduce myself in every video now
because who knows there's someone out
there that doesn't know who I am
I mistakenly clicked a link thinking
that they were gonna go watch iJustine
in surprise no you got this human turd
welcome to Friday refried diaries look
back at my weekend vlog form so let's
look back at some of the things that
have happened this week hell of an area
to Saturday and Chester and I are going
to a taping of a BDC America's Best
Dance Crew yeah we are yeah cuz d-trix
is on Quest Crew and Frankie and Frankie
is a judge and Quest Crew is one of the
last three crews so by the time this
video goes up afraid that you'll know
who won but as of this moment we don't
know d-trix Alexander there basically
owns a TDC his crew won season 3 oh the
judge for two seasons yeah and then now
he's back on his crew competing again if
he were to win again I mean he basically
his mystery biddies yeah and in my
opinion his crew has the best sense of
humor in their dance of all the pros
would you clerk like that and
ah
gaggle of [ __ ] these cars crew that
take on $100,000 grand prize and the
title of a EDC pole saw champion is
[Applause]
yay hello fry diary it is Sunday I'm
here with Wendy and Diane and we are in
a hotel downtown getting ready for the
VMAs today yes much Miley Cyrus very
Kardashian look at this makeup look at
the eyes yes Wendy yeah and Tyler Oakley
is on his way cuz he and I are promoting
the Streamy Awards all day today yes
come along with us on this magic carpet
ride look at the glamour of all of this
[Music]
hello Freud I are happy Monday I just
shot my video for Wednesday here's the
aftermath by now you know that I made em
neo pizza which is a fun way to make a
variety of pizzas that are inspired by
what you guys eat for lunch normally
give yourself something to look forward
to throughout the school day which as we
all know very much s is a D regularly
this is the cinnamon toast crunch the
cereal pizza oh so damn go fishing once
all of it can't happen I'll give you a
little piece of hotdog
oh yes hello fern I'm very happy
Thursday I just tried to go to the
gynecologist and but the gynecologist
was running a little late as she was
delivering a child she was bringing life
into this world ah but I have to run
home because we are shooting a very
special episode of not to date today
with kick the PJ Mitchell Davis and
maimry hart it's an Oscars Hotel special
edition I'm not too deep I'm so excited
that I didn't have a ton of time to wait
for goddamn life to get created I have
art to create so I had to bail on the
vagina women and go home and hang out
with a bunch of vaginas look who has
invaded my house just staring pensively
out of the window those wrongs yeah
wrong you know my mom's got some rocks
out front page a zoo he hopped across
the pond come and hang in your intro I
can't
but mamrie Hart here and Jack Faria
Mills here we and cashew nuts we just
recorded a special Oscars Hotel edition
of not too deep how did you guys think
it went I'll do it really bad okay
mm-hmm
oh look that's at the back of my head
looks like my life remains the same hi
Friday are you happy Thursday
I am I'm writing right now uh and I'm a
little blocked right now I'm writing so
I am talking to you guys I'm just brain
fried and I hate it I'm wearing some
moosh walks you don't know oka K is
designed these socks moosh walks some
roxy moosh walks they're designed in the
image of her dog which is adorable using
them to get some inspiration I'm also
making my way over to some iron-on
letters because I think I might make
myself a shirt right now to distract
myself from the creative blockage that's
happening in my brain whenever I'm
blocked in writing if I do some other
sort of craft project it usually works
as creative fiber
what's my brain you have so artistic you
didn't have to kill me I'm boring you
you guys ever want to know where God is
I keep him right outside my window or
her I haven't been able to make out the
face hi fry diary happy Friday
this in fact Friday it's like five or
six o'clock and I've been sitting as
that beast of a thing all day writing
yay oh no wait I wasn't doing that all
day I made this yeah I made I made that
I got to go to the gynecologist this
morning guys so if you're really
concerned about me not being able to go
the other day there is closure on that
and everything's great great um yeah my
brain is still fried I've already like a
maniac all week and will continue to be
writing all good things fun things dumb
things dumb fun things yes oh I found
out that
not only our Tyler and I hosting the
streamys but we're both nominated among
a munch a munch a munch oh I meant to
send many in a bunch much we're
nominated among a bunch of other really
amazing content creators for Entertainer
of the Year so if you want to vote for
me for Entertainer of the Year because
that's how that category works you vote
on it and then there is a winner you
have to tweet with the hashtag grace
Helbig
hashtag streamys and the word vote also
I tweeted on my account
everything that you need and if you just
retweet that tweet right here Bing that
counts you can vote a million times a
day but they will only count the first
hundred so you can do it every day until
they don't let you do it anymore so go
do that if you'd like to do that if you
don't have vote for me there's a whole
bunch of other really great people up
for your voting pleasure it's really
nothing else going on so that was my
weak fried re I hope that you enjoyed it
if you did give this video a thumbs up
leave a comment down below and subscribe
to this channel because all it takes is
that and you do more than that on a
toilet
so this place is pretty shape makes
sense to do it here too
I don't know are you chillin like a
villain I'm sorry are you chillin like a
villain test